[Musica]
sono una stand up comedian che uno già
dice che allora diciamo che il mio
lavoro consiste nel cercare di far
ridere le persone su argomenti spinosi
difficili sui tabù persino sulle paure
mi piace far ridere le persone dicendo
quelle cose che sul palco ok ma se le
dici per strada te menano allora io
definisco il mio lavoro mi piace dire
che mi piace mettere in discussione i
sistemi di pensiero dominante
quindi quando mi hanno chiamato per
questo ted
io sono stata inizialmente molto
contenta ma quando mi hanno comunicato
il tema appunto di riferimento pietra
miliare io sono andata immediatamente in
crisi ho pensato diversi giorni a quali
siano i miei punti di riferimento nella
vita ci ho pensato tanto ci pensavo e
più le cose mi sembravano piuttosto
degli stereotipi diciamo quando pensavo
a dei punti di riferimento universali mi
sembravano un po vuoti mi sembravano
piuttosto e delle abitudini quasi delle
gabbie ci ho pensato tanto sono stata un
giorno intero a guardare il soffitto a
un certo punto mi sono detta
oddio ma io non ho valori sono una tar
chicca non crede in nulla ea quel punto
ha pianto cioè a me questi del ted di
castelfranco veneto mi hanno fatto
piangere che si sappia cioè questa non è
una storia di successo e una storia di
crisi
io sono andata in crisi tavola che
piangeva disperata un certo punto mi
sono fermata e mi sono detta ammazza
però quanto mi piace piangere ea quel
punto mi sono messa a ridere o riso di
me che sto sempre a piangere e
finalmente ho capito di cosa vi avrei
potuto parlare cioè il mio punto di
riferimento nella vita e non piangere e
l'auto ironia autoironia e questa cosa
questo meccanismo che mi scatta
automaticamente nei momenti difficili
della vita è questo è questo istinto per
cui quando mi succede qualcosa nelle
relazioni sul lavoro anche quando dei
pensieri cattivi improvvisamente mi
viene in mente una battuta cioè viene in
mente un aspetto comico e questa cosa è
molto bella perché mi ha fatto
riflettere sul fatto che
caronia di fatto è proprio una forma di
auto con passione è una forma di di
autoaccettazione l'auto ronnie a è una
forma di pietas
ma vediamo un caso pratico poniamo il
caso che io abbia l'esigenza di piangere
che faccio chiamo un amico chiamo un
amico e comincia a piangere perché
piangere da soli è bello come piangere
in compagnia di qualcuno non so se ci
avete fatto caso
allora io ti chiamo e comincia a
piangere quando sono arrivata all'apice
della disperazione proprio che so tutta
rossano tutta sudata
non so se qua c'è qualcuno che su da
quando piange
io sono un sacco proprio che ce la metto
tutta quando piango professor quindi
quando arrivò tutta rossa tutta sudata
quando mi comincia a uscire il bocciolo
dal naso
a quel punto di solito mi viene in mente
una cosa divertente diciamo in bocciolo
il punto di rottura della crisi di
solito mamma vediamo a questo punto
proprio l'esempio pratico questa era la
teoria tempo fa mi ricordo stavo vivendo
un momento difficile ho chiamato una mia
amica ed ho iniziato a piangere perché
non riuscivo ad avere i figli tema
delicatissimo molto spinoso la mia amica
era in silenzio e mi guardava con una
faccia tipo quella della signora qui in
prima fila cioè così era chiaro pallida
in faccia da jano che stanno pensando
zitta non dire niente che se sbagli
questa si suicida e quindi io proverei a
lo guardavo i ostacolare le annuiva e
dicevo cosa lei che sa che io ero
disperatissima dico sarò solo io sarò
sola ti rendi conto
io sarà sola con i gatti io sarò una
caparra del cazzo sarò come quelle
persone che pensano che i gatti siano
come i loro figli
dico ma come si no sì no sì no nel senso
si può insomma alla fine i gatti però
uno gli vuole bene e li e li provo
quando il mucciolo sgorgava io ho
pensato ma sì ma sì alla fine è vero i
gatti diventare un po come dei figli
però so più comodi perché non gli devi
far fare la prima comunione
anche se io devo dire per la castrazione
2 bomboniere pensavo lo stesso di farle
mi sembrava una cosa carina ti voglio
bene a sti ca e a quel punto ho visto
che la mia amica ri ri fiorita proprio
rideva quattro ganasce ma era una risata
isterica ovviamente no mi capiterà per
la battuta rideva perché aveva capito
che non ha più chiamare le onoranze
funebri è ovvio mi sembra allora capit e
l'auto ronnie alla fine è una forma di
autocommiserazione evoluta nel senso che
vittimista diciamo no il vittimista
quello simplex dopo un po appesantisce
non servono come lo devi gestire invece
infetti mista autoironico si mette più a
tuo agio capito c'è un certo punto tu
quando vedi che esagera ti senti più
libero di mandarlo serenamente affanculo
è bella questa cosa
qualcuno si sarà riconosciuto perché
sennò quello che ha fatto partire
l'applauso sicuramente molto bella però
ecco torniamo un attimo il tema del
punto di riferimento cioè io sono andato
a tanti in crisi perché si ok l'auto
ronnie a è un mio modo d'essere dico non
sarà troppo autoreferenziale parlare di
questa cosa che mi riguarda direttamente
il fatto è proprio che quando riflettevo
sul tema mi sono resa conto che spesso i
nostri punti di riferimento
gli diamo un po per scontati cioè
accettiamo come punti di riferimento
della nostra vita piuttosto delle
convenzioni sociali per esempio questo
momento va tanto di moda a dio patria
famiglia è tornato un po di moda in
questo periodo
e io che vi devo dire se la carne questa
cosa mi suona così come un contenitore
vuoto mi suona più come un proclama che
altro non lo sento vero non lo sento mio
cioè mi fa uno strano effetto cioè
permetti io padre a famiglia
è un po come bere tanto mangiare le
verdure
e tonificare i glutei cioè alla fine mi
crea un certo disagio
entriamo nello specifico appena mi hanno
comunicato il tema io subito ho pensato
va beh per me nella mia vita sono molto
importanti i miei genitori
poi mi sono fermata un attimo ha detto
si vede apprezzare sul palco di un
tecnica alla finale di miss italia
cerchiamo di elaborare un attimo il
concetto e allora mi sono detta sì è
vero i genitori sono sicuramente un
riferimento importante
il loro affetto è necessario e perfino
irrinunciabile non lo metto in dubbio
però se io penso alla donna che e mia
madre effettivamente lei è stata un
punto di riferimento totale per me un
faro perché io non ho ripercorso neanche
una delle sue scelte nella vita quindi
totale veramente c'è allora mi dico per
questo grazie viva le mamme evviva le
mamme per questo dico cioè se io non
elaborarsi questo modello noi abbiamo il
dovere verso noi stessi di elaborare i
modelli che abbiamo che abbiamo
assorbito perché se io non avessi
elaborato il modello di mia madre adesso
mi sentirei una fallita perché non sono
sposata non ho figli sono una gattara e
soprattutto raramente riesco a tenere i
gomiti attaccate i fianchi quando sono a
tavola
quindi ok ho rielaborato questo modello
mia madre rimane un faro da un altro
punto di vista nel senso che non ha mai
giudicato la mia vita così tanto diversa
dalla sua che insomma è una cosa
importante ma l'autonomia perché per me
è così importante perché è una forma di
auto consapevolezza cioè un modo per
conoscersi un pochino meglio ed in
questo senso diventa anche una forma di
autodifesa specialmente verso quelle
persone che si prendono troppo sul serio
eco saper ridere di se stessi è una
buona arma verso chi si prende troppo
sul serio
ma vediamo un secondo caso di studio
l'altro giorno ho letto un commento
sotto mio video pubblico su youtube che
recitava così a me sta comica mi fa pena
allora dico grazie la pietas e un
sentimento nobile dice no inutile che
fai la cosa spiritosa che rispondi
ironica proprio che mi fai schifo non è
un sentimento nobile accetta le critiche
di che no io le critiche tendono
accettarle solo quando sono mosse da un
sentimento nobile tipo l'aggravamento
sessuale ecco è una cosa tipo quello che
mi ha scritto quando ti guardo in tv
video ce l'ho duro ecco quello di un
pochino già più già più mi interessa di
più
quindi dico è importante capite per il
mio lavoro l'auto aironi a no ma mica
del far ridere
no no no per far ridere servono le
tecniche serve la tecnica si impara come
si scrive come si sta sul palco non ho
di cola toroni a nel mio lavoro è
importante proprio per sopravvivere
acquisti che non ci hanno il senso
dell'umorismo è in questo senso qui però
voglio dire c'è tanta gente c'è tanta
gente che medita ci sono persone che
meditano io questa sera umilmente mi
proporrei di praticare la autoironia 10
minuti al giorno
come si fa voi tornate a casa dopo una
giornata un po diciamo complicata una
giornata complessa una giornata di merda
diciamolo tornate a casa e siete un po
abbacchiati abbattuti arrivi consiglio
vi mettete lì vi ripercorrete un attimo
e quei momenti che che vi hanno messo un
po in difficoltà e cercate di trovarne
un lato umoristico cercate di vedervi
voi in qualche modo più piccoli un po
più indifesi ma anche un po più
spiritosi perché sapete che c'è questo
imparato nel mio lavoro
una risata non li seppellirà ma vi
aiuterà senz'altro a sentirvi un pochino
meno incazzati un pochino meno
arrabbiati un pochino meno frustrati e
per le donne
ve lo dico a me l'auto rioni anni fa
pure senti meno gonfia giuro altro che
l'impresa
[Applauso]